why do you think you were like easy to
hate if that's an okay question well
look i was like
young and wearing [ __ ] cool jeans
did you ever be honest dude have you
ever worn fur
i never wore fur not faux
first hopefully i would assume being
from massachusetts you go with real fur
dude
that's paul revere country you guys have
earned the real fur
uh but did you ever wear fur no i did
not no no we didn't but my mom had some
fur coats that's
awesome so i probably did throw one of
my mom's fur
but not once you got it popular no once
i once i made it i was
it was like uh you know tight shirts
and um you know the image that i was
trying to create um
steve martin the white suit the the
the dichotomy of being like hey i'm
dressed up really nice but i'm being
like wacky and
and then dice of course the element of
uh of like badass and
cool eddie murphy and the you know
leather outfit
i was figuring out hey you know what my
thing is like i'm
i'm coming up with this next generation
and dudes are more fashionista
in many ways than you know in the past
so
i just found my niech and i played up on
that
and then i i could understand years
later looking back like
oh my god i wouldn't have liked that guy
either wow you know
it's it's uh you know hindsight is an
incredible
incredibly prolific thing um and
you don't know at the time you just
think you're you know i don't know just
you're doing the best you can to try to
create an image that
um that resonates yeah you know and you
did a great job so
at certain points because when you say
like you know the
jealous scene did it uh theo i wasn't i
wasn't looking at that
i was looking at 20 000 people i wasn't
looking at the
one guy in the comment section who was
right of course yeah you know so look
into the master
square garden you're looking at the the
proof that was in front of you yeah is
that everything i'm doing is right
yeah it was like i was just looking at
um the love from
the fans that i had uh found or who
found me
so it really didn't hit me until many
many years later of like oh wow there's
really some genuine animosity
and it's just up to me to have
conversations like this
with my peers with the brotherhood of
comedy
to say i'm accessible and you know you
know if you're a fan i'm accessible
you could dm me i write everybody back
sometimes people write me and say hey
man i'm having a shitty day and i go
here's what you need to do
yeah cause i'm super sensitive and i'm
empathetic to that
so the perception of me very different
than
who i am um when i'm just you know at
home
kicking it yeah yeah it's interesting
yeah because that's i mean
yeah if i'm real candid it was just like
yeah what is dan like
dane seems like this i don't know yeah
like this
kind of like this pluto kind of like
this thing where people don't
know but for some reason people have
felt rubbed the wrong way
you know yeah but then also has probably
had the ability to
garner a huge amount of jealousy over
time as well
so yeah there's a lot of factors in
there i bet it was probably hard to sift
through some of that if you even wanted
to look at it
it was it was like uh because it it
didn't it wasn't even though it wasn't
affecting me directly in terms of like
business it affected like
my fans didn't like feeling like they
were
yeah then if you were a dane fan then it
was like weird right there was a period
where it's like people were like hey am
i
i say i like you and then i get attacked
by other people yeah
but we used to win a wheelchair because
i was yeah
your madison square garden 20 000 c show
what you start to realize what's going
on bro here's the
here's the breakthrough breaking news in
what everybody
learns when you become successful and
what you're learning
you know right now you're in the pink
cloud phase everything's
you know everybody's finding you and
discovering you and passing around
um everything is mediocre
everything every single thing is
mediocre aerosmith i love him
there's somebody going i don't that's
not my thing
you can't name a book a a magician
nobody definitely can't name a magician
you can't name magicians can we just
admit magicians are comedians
are arch nemesis i mean that should be
who else is it
yeah it should be a movie dude and it
definitely should be a movie
who else could our arch nemesis be um uh
no that's it it has to win magicians
no everything is you find out uh success
introduces you to
uh mediocrity because then everybody
outside of your realm
um is gonna tell you why you're not that
great and
and what sucks about you you know you
can we we're watching careers
right now of people let's just say in
the last five years and what do they do
they get white hot
and then um you know and then it's like
the spanking machine
everybody's going to get tagged and
we're going to find things out that we
don't like about them and then
what happens is your your fan base the
bottom of the v right here
they're still you know pretty much rock
solid in place most of them
and then everybody out here is in the
business of
telling you yeah we don't care right and
they want to tell you and they're going
to reach out to tell you
all we can do just come up with the next
set next joke
get up on stage try to have a few more
laughs with our friends family
and then um do one more show that's
that's what i'm doing
yeah we definitely seem to be really
fearless you know that's for sure like
just because like you grew up in fear to
continue to keep your head down and keep
going grew up in fear
when you grew up in fear based which i
was
then man just you know
once i once i found this um
conduit comedy once i had that
it was like the dilithium crystal i had
[ __ ] superpowers
i had this ability to actually be um
present
and important to people when i didn't
even feel important to myself
right it took a long time for all those
things to equate
um a well-rounded
healthy lifestyle both on and off
stage you know to be able to have great
conversations like this yeah
you know do you um did you have an idea
what you thought
like being a star was or something like
that before you
like hit like a level of stardom
popularity oh what a great question man
that that um i remember
um rob you know seeing guys like robin
williams
playing uh like garp and
like a world of heart nagar yeah oh dude
that's one of my favorite books of all
time
love it book amazing the film you know
awesome he was awesome
and i was looking at a lot of comedic
actors
um and admiring that they could tell
different kinds of story they could make
you laugh maybe they could make you cry
to me that was like uh an interesting um
route for a career so what i did and
where
it plays into the question is like i i
took my foot off the gas
of what i knew people had um
discovered me as and was like i'm gonna
downshift
and try to go in that direction so i
could have some more credibility and
outside of comedy um deconstructed
myself really in the mid
you know 2000 here like with films and
stuff like that with that kind of work
yeah because then i started getting some
opportunity to do things that were very
different from stand-up based on my
stand-up kevin costner was a fan of my
stand-up and then said
do you want to play a serial killer in
this movie with me and it was like
suddenly that was when i felt a certain
level of stardom when i was
um not so much from the comedy ever
but from the um
being received and this all comes back
to inclusion and feeling isolated as a
kid
you know kevin costner's and demi
moore's and juliette benosh and
steve carell people that i i loved to
watch them do things that were so
drastically different we're now saying
hey you
you know right yeah you're then you're
only one of us yeah so that's when i
started to feel
a bit of um oh wow i i'm i'm in a
i'm in a different uh circle right an
inner circle and do you
do you feel like then you start treating
people differently like like was there
was there a point you felt like
like looking back like oh i was an
[ __ ] you know i never felt like i was
an [ __ ]
i never felt like uh i had never gotten
to a place where i
like i had seen some other comedians in
some other
behaviors um you know there was eddie
griffin
[Laughter]
um there were some magicians out there
actually who were [ __ ]
[ __ ] um siegfried and tiger face
whatever that guy's name was i saw that
uh i saw some behavior in other um
not even just comedians but just in
other celebrities you know having been
in la for bed
and i thought it was really deplorable
and i wanted to be a person that uh
if if you could approach me if you felt
like i was approachable that
uh you know there was something to be
gleaned from both my success and failure
so i i never felt like an [ __ ] i
i would listen to people talk about me
you know joan rivers i'd never met and
she called me an [ __ ]
on stern i never met her i never made a
joan rivers joke i respected that woman
yeah she you know she was cool built it
in and
cool and funny and always funny she used
all the racial slurs once on tmz and
it's still one of my favorite clips i'll
watch it at night sometimes before bed
what's your bedtime regimen it is like
you put on some creams and then you
watch
jones he's like somebody said this and
somebody's at this and somebody's at
this and somebody's of this and people
just need to get used to it
well joan you know called me an [ __ ]
and i remember i was
you never met her never met her never
met her and i was uh
man i was like mortified why did you
think that oh
either a i'm such an [ __ ] that it's
reached joan rivers like the rumor of it
no that what is going on that people
think this
or just that i've become a name that
people for some reason associate with
this you know what if i was gonna get
really um if i was gonna go deep into
like the
the the human element the id super id
what's going on with this
i would say i the one thing i didn't
realize how to do
was um reach out early in my career when
i broke through to
to celebrate some of the comedians that
came before me if i met you i would i
would i met dice at the pizza place
um and and i can only i'm guess i'm
guessing but maybe it maybe it hurt her
that i had
arrived and maybe didn't shout her out
right you know cause we're all so
[ __ ] sensitive yeah and what i've
learned about her from other people was
hey man she was
she was very sensitive too see we're
we're all that
um and so the having
people call you an [ __ ] from time to
time is uh it was
actually kind of um it was confusing
was it uplifting in a weird way though
was there part of your ego or part of
you i mean
part of any of our ego or like at least
they're talking about me
well the the part that you
because you've had and i ask you this
because you've had so i mean
you know there's not anybody else that i
could think of that's had the same
story that you've had the best part
about being being
considered uh you know being ostracized
in a way where people think you're like
the bad guy or an [ __ ] or whatever is
for me i can only talk about my
experience but for me it was like
good this is an armor to keep the people
that have hurt
me my whole life away because they're a
little scared of me
because they think i'm something beyond
just a regular guy which i'm just a
regular dude
i'm just funny for an hour and a half on
stage
and otherwise i i'm pretty basic you
know
i'm jeans and t-shirt kind of guy and uh
you know so
that to that extent i didn't mind uh
uh i didn't mind everybody uh having an
opinion on me and
i didn't really mind if it was harsh it
just started to hurt
when my fans were really included in my
family you know even my family like
why'd this tabloid say this about you or
um that's when it started to get a
little confusing yeah cause i was like
oh i'm just here to
make people laugh and you know i get it
nobody loves everything
right people don't love you but um
it was a little weird you know even
looking back and talking about it now
it's still like what did i ever do to
anybody except just try to
get laughs the greatest thing that we
can do is try to
get laughs you know yeah i'm trying to
it wasn't like i'd get laughs and people
would be
withering and dying and it's like give
me all the power of laughs
right where it's like you would leave an
empty [ __ ] theater of just corpses
and you're like i'm an [ __ ] i steal
souls it was just like no i just want to
make you forget about your [ __ ]
hardship
for a little bit and if people take
issue with that then that's
what other people think of you is none
of your business yeah you know i try to
i try to implement that
yeah i don't know why i wonder why that
thing why that thing surrounded you so
much then that it was like
i remember the first time um
yeah i just wonder why that surrounded
you so but but it doesn't now
which is kind of funny because if you
talk to people now
uh or even somebody talks to you it's
like no once you talk to me and once you
hang with me be like oh man he's
he's pretty level-headed you know i'm
not
a person that has a lot of foibles
otherwise man i'm right i'm pretty i you
know i'm a i'm a boston kid
and we say it like it is and wear our
heart on our sleeves
and i'm not into playing a character i'm
into my
journey for the next many years of my
life is like how can i be more present
how can i be more real how can i be more
um
uh authentic yeah you know organic
that's that's my journey now
wow yeah it's interesting man it's such
a yeah because after we hung out i was
like
i was like i don't know what i don't
know if
you know i didn't know what thing i was
like dane seemed so like
normal and and
and it had i had never and i told you my
preconceived notion
of you yeah i was very honest with you
about saying hey man i prejudged you as
well i thought like oh this is a guy
that's like trying to make it out of
some other career and yeah
is he really uh a purist and and i was
uh you know i i wrongly did the same
thing
yeah i took that card you left my house
that day and i was like i could
grab a lunch with that guy yeah i like
him you know you're really uh you're
deep
you're a deep guy and you're [ __ ]
funny you know you're you're you're
funny you deliver on stage
everybody knows it everybody's chatting
about it um so i admire that but
i like that you can do this right you
know i wish in some ways i had more of
this
maybe around that time right where the
[ __ ] were you theo you could have helped
yeah i don't know dude i was probably
doing cocaine come on crispy von dogs
let's go hashtag crispyvontans well
thanks for watching that video right
there that was a beautiful little
segment i think
but of course i'm partisan to myself but
you can move on to another video right
now you can check on this video or on
this video
that's two different options and you can
also subscribe to the channel
check on our new video subscribe to the
channel check subscribe
check check subscribe